イブとイブトラップ
同じ髪型これじゃあ外れたぞと言うというわけで心霊スポットは東京の有名どころです
ね
もう東京じゃないでも全国的に全国的に有名なんですか有名
僕基本的に静岡の心霊スポット方を攻めたんですけどもまぁ東京に来てせっかくなので
こちらの心霊スポットも行ってみたいなというふう
のでちょっとホンダ大樹さんと一緒に行ってみますうっしゃい朝は4時10分です
時間がなんか4:44ですよヤバイ気がせませんやばいやばいですよね今回行くバスは
ちょっとまた説明しないですね
運が良い食わすなんですけども2017東京や関東通報で一番怖い規模な盲心霊
スポットはどこっていうそういう綺麗な記事があったんですけども
させる-22番目吹上トンネルという場所でございますでどういう場所かといいますと
東京都 o 3市にある古いトンネルですここでは昔近所で茶屋を営んでいた親子が
強盗に襲われ母親は店で殺され娘がトンネル逃げ込んだもののそこで捕まり殺されたと
いう
私があります
でそれら夜中にここを通ると娘の例が出現すると言われているとまさに
p 時間ですね乳児ぐらいの場所的には神吹上トンネルに入る手前に右入る道があって
そこいくと旧吹上トンネルがあります車止めがあるんでね
ちゃんと止める場所があるのでそこから歩いて行けるらしいですなんか周辺
には小さなトンネルが多くあるらしくてまあ結構スポットとして有名らしいでござい
ます
では早速もやっていきましょう
すごい東京の心霊スポットってた僕違和感しかないですよね
どうしてん
なんか静岡とかだといい仲が多いから山道とか意外となんか怖いんですけどと信じが
倒壊だ中にあるシーンですことという感じだったろうと聞いてね
yeah いいこいつ
簿記
んだけど
色は全て入ってきましたまっへ結構でも山1雰囲気いい雰囲気
ルーターの血液が出せていいですかうよええええですねえ外れ
某ですね世界ねやっぱり一発分かりました
耳鼻口はラゴスいない
どちゃナビ帰りな
ベビー正解ですいいぜ同じ手段だった使う
すごい米びっぽいですか無いっぽい日置さんのスマホのキャリアてていいですか
良いさんいいですいや違うな所ですね
どこまで by 藍蓼藍がー
ぜひああやっぱりなっても近いですかね
急になんか来たりやばいなーこれはもうちょいいくとも出てくれますトンネルで飛んだ
ようですね
趣味君君
マルホ止めれますではここだ
多分配置を上げてつきましたこちらですね
ここに入ってここに停めれるとそうそうここ
左側にあるトンネルが新規安芸郡
この右奥にあるらしい q がなるほど
よしよはい
いますかよしここですねどこ
これが好き上げトンネル新スイング
が元気得ると思う
2 h
なんかすごい泣いてますよめっちゃ10本本当にはがやばくない
なんでこんななく
勤務中年ぐらいない赤ですねはいそういうわけで
つきましたこちらです
引き上げトンネル
明るい
これ結構ユージーモードじゃないですか
でも
えっ
[音楽]
ふらふらしてきたうんっ
うわぁこれ
なんかが剃り方は凄い凄いがそれ方がすごい
いやー見えてない
アルト牌譜よ開いてこい誰がこう言ってしてるー
ラキストってません ana
f あっも後ろ見えない moon
[音楽]
多そうでお願いしました
そうだでとは思いません
なかなか恐怖ですわれ
池貝か
[音楽]
me
さってます
ええええええ
今決めましたーーー
これでゴン的稼ぐサどちらもしれん
ねえっまっなにわ翁
ここで a
ましょうん
wa エイドもいい
[音楽]
ません
それ
翔さん
ん
うん
ええええええ
プールって落ちるバーもダメだ俺もだめだもうだめだぞ
2分とれています
撮れてますよねー一緒に行かないですよなんかこっちに来ませんですねっ
[音楽]